[Music]
nothing but thanks thanks so much there
dude
yeah yeah get in here come on come on
get it hop in it is really really fun
here then give me a poem what we got
tickling right there oh man no you
missed come on I have bubbles in here ya
gotta get up that phone phone keeps
ringing good like carry you up into a
mountain show the world like that okay
this is my lover ha ha never one look
hey hon yeah what come on real quick oh
yeah what's up why are you a little
massage tents I want to do that's so
nice of you know right off you huh wow
you're very good at that thanks big I
got it oh yeah get it get it out of here
frozen feels really good yeah I really
appreciate it you just we just do it
they're just you talk weird can you just
talk normal please I mean what do you
really talk this is this is how I said
hippie yeah this is it this is all I
have okay I keep thinking it's like a
joke baby
like are you putting something on that
no she's just make it more like a woman
kitchen vocally be horrible woman
I understand um I understand maybe like
just struggling with the voice it's
really hard for me my bad that's pretty
good I mean like right
that's so hot I like that that's way
better I love you so like yeah that's
way better yes
yes we did it that's why solder problems
man you're the best you're the best
hahahah different boys thought bad and
weather really good yeah